okay hey guys really sorry to say this  but I've been in the hospital overnight  it's about 4 a.m. right now I'm hooked  up to a lot of scary-looking machines  but I don't want you guys to worry I'm  not will go into detail what's wrong  with me but it's nothing  life-threatening just involve love pain  came really suddenly so I hope to be out  of here as soon as possible  but if I miss some videos you know  there's nothing I can do about it cuz  I'm stuck here they need to observe me  and make sure that I'm okay and get some  x-rays and whatnot so soon as all that's  taken care of in a back home I should be  hundred percent and then I'll let you  guys know but just thanks guys for  supporting me I do I freak some people  out with the tweet and pictures that I  put out there but really truly I'm okay  now I'm gonna be okay so thank you guys  for watching bye